[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
art de vivre et spéciale Eveline terre
de l'art de vivre puisque vous allez
voir que bah on peut tout se procurer
dans dans les evelines du saumon froid
gras en passant par les chocolats les
fromages évidemment on va vous donner
envie de faire des des repas de fête
formidables mais c'est aussi des repas
que vous pouvez faire tout le reste de
l'année avec avec nos invités avec
Laurent trochin bonjour bonjour Patrice
vous êtes vous êtes un chef étoilé
depuis une vingtaine d'années à trembler
sur moldre dans votre restaurant qui
s'appelle numéro 3 et alors là vous avez
cherché loin parce que c'est au numéro 3
de la rue Charles de GA he c'est çaou
tout à fait voilà c'est aussi difficile
que ça à comprendre et on va parler
aussi de de parce que vous êtes le
créateur du du Yolin tout à fait oui et
alors ça ça va ça
va entraîner la la la mobilisation bah
de toutes les villes de tous les
villages des ivelines à partir du du
mois de janvier et de tous les habitants
qui vont pouvoir faire des des recettes
il y aura un concours on va on vous
allez nous expliquer parler tout à
l'heure euh Jeffrey vanal bonjour
bonjour alors vous vous êtes vous êtes
vous avez une ferme qui a un nom
absolument formidable c'est la ferme du
loup ravissant c'est ça c'est bien ça
oui la ferme du loup ravissant vous
m'expliquerez tout à l'heure d'où ça
vient problème et alors vous êtes vous
êtes alors vous produisez évidemment des
légumes he de les ferme et puis du
canard du canard gras et notamment du
foie gras on est les derniers
producteurs des ivelines de foie gras on
élève nos canards à la ferme on a la on
a la le laboratoire de transformation
donc on fait tout de A à Z donc le le
foie gras des ilines c'est vous c'est ça
Ludovic Bizau bonjour bonjour Patrice
vous êtes fromager comme votre vest
l'indique vous êtes meilleur ouvrier de
France vous êtes rambouillé dans un
votre votre boutique si je peux dire
s'appelle toutun fromage par que je je
crois que vous aimez beaucoup les jeux
de mot donc ça peu de vous savez comment
on appelle un jeu de mot fait avec un
nom de fromage c'est un camambour ah
c'est bien ah faudra l'inventer peutêtre
manger du
camambour M du monre en rayon par
exemple ça peut être ça Éric barnou
bonjour oui bonjour Patrice euh alors
vous êtes un spécialiste de la on
appelle ça la fumaison hein tout à fait
ou oui on dit fumeur vous êtes on dit
fumeur on dit artisan fumeur tout à
faità comme vous voulez et alors vous
êtes vous êtes vous à jouer en Josas
dans un établissement qui s'appelle la
fumerie du coin euh et vous êtes voilà
installé depuis une quinzaine d' ah ça
fait que ça ne fait que 6 7 ans ououa
ouais ouais on a commencé en 2017 just
avant les fêtes de 2017 ouais 201 et et
et c'est une maison absolument
formidable évidemant pour les fêtes il y
a il y a le saumon mais il y a d'autres
poissons qu'on qu'on qu'on fume que vous
fumez tout au long de l'année ouais ouis
exactement ben je vous en parlerai on a
le saumon qui est important qui est très
aimé des des Français et puis pas mal
d'autres d'autres produits et et puis je
vous remercie parce que vous êtes tous
venu avec des produits donc on a déjà
déjà envie d'être d'être table et avec
nous Hélène Colas bonjour bonjour euh
alors vous êtes vous êtes aussi venu
avec un un un un coffre un trésor trésor
hein c'est trésor de votre chocolaterie
vous êtes vous
êtes à à moule c'est ça hein c'est ça
depuis 50 ans voilà c'est une maison qui
qui est familiale he depuis 50 ans ça
mes parents ont démarré l'activité et
puis j'ai repris avec mes frères il y a
bientôt 30 ans maintenant d'accord et et
alors c'est amusant de s'appeler Cola
quand on fait du choc colat
oui ça ça doit influencer un peu il y en
a qui font des routes mais il faut vaut
mieux faire du on travaille pour eux ils
mangent du chocolat colat ça ils adorent
avoir colat sur le ballottin on faire du
chocolat euh on on va commencer avec
vous Laurent trochin euh d'abord un mot
donc ce ce ce restaurant numéro 3 vous
avez vous êtes étoilé au Michelin depuis
une vingtaine d'années hein c'est ça ça
fera 20 ans le 13 février 2024 alors euh
j'ai lu une chose peut-être
peut-être que que je frerai on va en
parler aussi avec vous dans dans vos
dans vos les menus que vous proposez
hein chez vous vous dites voilà il y a
un changement dans la façon de de de
faire de la cuisine aujourd'hui pendant
longtemps bah les légumes ont accompagné
la viande et le poisson et on entre dans
une nouvelle ère si je peux dire où
c'est le légume qui va être le plus
important et le poisson la viande vaut
plutôt être des accompagnements ouais
tout à fait parce que on parle beaucoup
en ce moment de de de de manger moins
manger mieux évidemment mais mais en
même temps c'est c'est toute logique
quoi c'est-à-dire le légume le végétal
ben il doit être nous ça fait partie de
notre alimentation depuis tout petit
donc et aujourd'hui on le voit de plus
en plus dans tout style de restaurant
oui que que tout est transformé qu'il y
a vraiment tout est inversé quoi entre
la protéine animale et et les légumes et
et d'ailleurs quand on vous regarde vos
men alors il y a un menu végétarien mais
il y a un menu avec du la viande et du
poisson et c'est vrai que vous commencez
par la description des des légumes avant
euh ouais toujours parce que c'est c'est
notre façon de faire aussi à nous c'est
notre alimentation donc mais mais
surtout sans oublier de que la protéine
animale est importante et j'insiste
toujours voilà c'est que oui on a une
cuisine qui qui est qui est très
végétale mais la protéine animale est
très importante jeffre Val ça ça vous
gêne pas vous oh aucun problème j'adore
les légumes et j'adore la viande donc
oui et pui vous produisez aussi des des
légumes et alors il y a une autre
spécificité dans dans votre restaurant
euh c'est bah que vous vous vous
privilégiez les les produits euh locaux
si je peux dire enfin ou départementaux
en tout casou ouais tout à fait on est
on est très Eveline he très 78 on est à
90 % avec des des producteurs des
éleveurs mais toute entreprise des
Yvelines voilà j'insiste surtout c'est
entreprise des zblines euh et c'est
c'est une évidence il y a 20 ans quand
on est arrivit il y avait pas autant de
de de produits et là aujourd'hui on a
une multitude de produits ça s'est
multiplié par euh par ça en TER on en a
un petit aperçuou ici d'ailleurs moi je
voilà le fois gras moi je pensais que
c'était dans le Sud-Ouest donc on va
voir c'est aussi dans les ivblines vous
disez je crois qu'il y a il y a qu'un
produit qui est pas purement invivinois
c'est le beurre il nous manque du beurre
tout à fait ouais il y a la ferme de il
y a de la crème il y a du lait il y a
les œufs il il y a tout ce qu'on veut
mais pas de beurre donc il y a la ferme
de Grignon qui en fait quelquefis comme
ça deux fois par an mais on a pas de
beurre alors on a de la crème épaisse
après on peut entre guillemets s'amuser
à faire du beurre avec la crème épaisse
fermière à plus de 36 % voilà mais mais
on n pas on a pas de producteur de
bizarre parce que c'est pas très
compliqué si de faire du beurre ben
c'est de la technique comme tout métier
hein c'est une question technique puis
après c'est une question de cûp aussi l
pour en parler du litre de lait pour
faire de la crème par rapport au litre
de lait pour faire du fromage il y a une
grosse différence aussi donc c'est un
système complet le beurre c'est une
partie de la matière grasse du lait donc
pour fabriquer du beurre il faut aussi
pouvoir écouler du lait écrémé ou des
fromages au lait écrémé donc c'est c'est
un système complet que font très bien
les Normands ou d'autres producteurs
dans les terroirs mais un peu moins en
île defance pe Mo en île defance ouais à
part tout ça à part le beurre donc on
trouve absolument tout dans les iines on
trouve de tout en petite quantité mais
on trouve de tout VO de l'eau au vin en
passant par le poisson la viande voilà
et et c'est de là euh que vous avez dit
l'idée de créer le Yolin tout à fait
alors vous allez expliquer qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire Yolin y o l i n ouais alors
tout à fait donc le Y pour les ivelines
bien sûr le E pour olympique parce que
c'est 24 voilà le le le 24 le 26 juillet
pour démarrer les Jeux Olympiques le L
pour le local et le i pour inclusif
parce qu'on met tout le monde dans la
boucle voilà c'est ça alors euh il faut
expliquer on y reviendra parce qu'on en
reparlera évidemment ça va se lancer
l'année prochaine donc on en reparlera
au mois de janvier euh mais le Yolin au
fond c'est une base que relativement
simple euh c'est la c'est la la la patte
qu'on retrouve dans la dans la quich le
la quiche le Yolin c'est une quiche sans
pte voilà c'est une quiche sans patte
pour résumer mais ce qui est intéressant
dans le Yolin c'était d'avoir une base
et après que que que chacun puisse
s'approprier la recette al une be
relativement simple voà œuf farine lait
voilà bon c'est le poivre c'est un plat
salé mais surtout après vu le nombre de
d'entreprises et métiers de bouche dans
les evvelines ben c'est que chacun il
trouve sa patte et chacun puisse
utiliser le Yolin pour montrer son
entreprise voilà voilà alors il va y
avoir un concours encore une fois on en
parlera plus précisément au mois de
janvier mais dans toutes les villes et
et les villages des ivelines ça fait 200
259 59 voilà et tous les habitants
peuvent participer les 1500000 habitants
des iblines vont pouvoir participer il y
aura un gagnant par commune tout à fait
un gagnant par commune l'idée c'est de
rajouter à cette patte de quiche bah
trois produits hein evelinois voilà
c'est c'est vraiment le le but la charte
de du Yolin c'est qu'il y ait toujours
au minimum trois producteurs identifiés
ou entreprises identifié des métier de
bouche avec chaque recette du Yolin
c'est ça et et alors évidemment vous
disiez il va y avoir un un gagnant par
par village par ville village et et il y
aura un livre aura livre avec qui
regroupera bah tous les
gagnants 259 recettes et 259 gagnants
voilà avec le livre qui sortira un mois
avant les Jio le 26 juin c'est génial
non hein super vous allez participé donc
évidemment hein oui évidemment en plus
oui c'est relativement simple c'est vrai
c'est c'est vrai que cé la porté même
des gens qui sont pas des des cuisiniers
professionnels ou des ou des
spécialistes comme comme vous tous ici
euh l'important était là vraiment c'est
de rentrer dans les foyers que chacun
vraiment s'approprie le le Yolin quoi
voilà vive le Yolin on en reparlera
évidemment en janvier puisque c'est là
que ça va se lancer l'opération donc on
en parler plus précisément il y a déjà
un site hein S qui s'appelle Yolin
ww.le-yolin.fr
oui mar vous trouvez tout de suite voilà
alors
euh évidemment alors c'est c'est grâce à
vous que bah son sont réunis tous nos
invités ici parce que vous les
connaissez par votre profession et et
vous connaissez leur qualité alors
peut-être le repas on va peut-être
commencer par le par le par le poisson
par l'entrée
allons-yc Éric
alors vot il a la passion de de de la
fum maison j'ai comprendre que vous avez
eu très jeune vers he 17 18 ans ouais
ouais ouais on a commencé à faire des
beaux produits avec des avec mon frère
et des des amis ouais dans le jardin
familial don du poisson fumé mais aussi
du magré fumé toutes ces belles choses
vous avez l'idée de ça parce qu'on a
toujours bien aimé manger voilà on a
empêché un petit peu donc voilà
céit repas familiot et entre amis on a
évolué on a développé des techniques euh
voilà on s'est euh moi je me suis ça me
plaisait beaucoup je me suis un peu
spécialisé là-dessus j'ai fait
totalement autre chose d'autres études
euh voilà et d'autres métiers auparavant
et donc c'est une reconversion pas seul
on verra tout à l'heure qu' il y a des
il y a des trajectoires très
intéressantes parmi vous euh c'est ça et
puis après vous avez rencontré un
spécialiste de la fum maison qui en
Normandie je crois ouais tout à fait
ouais ouais à Grandville qui m'a voilà
qui m'a qui m'a éclairé sur pas mal de
sujets notamment technique je venais pas
du milieu de l'agroalimentaire donc donc
j'ai pu voir un petit peu de l'Intérieur
comment ça se passait euh et ensuite ben
voilà des passages chez des aringises
pour découvrir le métier en laboratoire
laboratoire de poissonnier on va
dire globalement et puis après il a
fallu se lancer et aès Arve 2017 là oui
exactement il y a pas d'école de
d'artisans fumeur donc c'est c'est des
choses que je connaissais j'avais pu
voir et puis beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
pas d'é col ouié col nexiste pas prs de
de
spécialistes comp
c'est ça c'est des alors moi je ah oui
c'est bizarre pas TR su souvent contacté
effectivement par des gens qui veulent
se lancer donc après on a rien à à
cacher c'est relativement simple la fuma
maison de poisson mais il faut bien le
faire voilà pour que ça soit bon voilà
c'est avoir des bons produits à la base
ce qui est le cas pour beaucoup de
beaucoup de métiers et tout le monde
reconnaz que vous le faites
exceptionnellement donc je vous
laisse 2017 installé à joui en Josas j
Josas ouais tout à fait c'était mon fè
il y a votre laboratoire et puis il y a
a un point de vente he ouais ouais un
petit accueil le but initialement
c'était de montrer aux gens que tout
était bien fait chez nous donc c'est un
laboratoire qui est ouvert sur un petit
accueil donc quand les gens viennent
récupérer des des produits ils voi
clairement le fumoir la salle de travail
derrière on est complètement
transparent voilà et on est aussi un
point de vente sur marché NotreDame ver
au marché de de Versailles le weekend
enfin ouais vendredi et dimanche matin
ouais pour toucher le plus grand nombre
de de personnes voilà et mais tout en
voilà on est sur un nous sur une zone de
une zone de chalandise pardon qui est
très restreinte voilà nos clients ils
sont juste autour de chez nous on est
vraiment au cœur de notre territoire
entre guillemets zone de chalandise et
c'était l'objectif initialement on est
on a des clients du coin du coin VO et
vous avez aussi un site j'ai vu que ça
marche très bien parce que même les
commandes pour Noël c'est un peu tard
ouais ou til d' venu parce a grand
plaisir plaisir mais on peut on peut
commander tout le reste de l'année ouais
ouais ouais sur les fêtes on est sur une
activité qui est très très saisonnière
en particulier sur le sur le saumon fumé
ce qui reste saumon fumé euh alors pas
n'importe quel saum alors c'est du
saumon d'élevage hein ouais alors on est
on reste sur du saumon d'élevage on fait
de la truite aussi on est on reste sur
de de la truite d'élevage on a pris le
parti de partir de proposer d'autres
poissons sauvages
euh donc on est sur une base que les
gens aiment de la fruite du saumon euh
et on on veut proposer d'autres produits
pour faire découvrir aux gens aussi
d'autres poissons fumés de pêche de
pêche coôtiè des poissons qui sont pas
habituellement consommés en en fumison
en fuma maison oui c'est qu'on trouve
chez vous ouais ouais donc on va avoir
je vous ai ramené voilà des sardines
fumées du fléant de l'aigle finin on
fait du mulet noir fumé qui est pas un
poisson qui est très mise en valeur et
qui est absolument délicieux du bar il y
a beaucoup de poulpes en ce moment en
Bretagne on va faire du poupe fumé à
partir de l'année prochaine ah génial
voilà on teste on teste beaucoup de
beaucoup oui c'est ça parce que c'est
vrai que quand on parle poisson fumé on
pense tout de suite au saon évidemment
alors ça va être le grand must
évidemment pour pour les les Vau D'cos
d'Irlande on est ouais surign sur mer
j'ai vu ouais alors il y a eu en ce
moment il y avait deux élevages français
qui éta à isign à Cherbourg il y a voilà
donc on a travaillé on a travaillé avec
les deux c'est un peu plus compliqué en
ce moment on espère pouvoir retravailler
avec un petit peu dans votre avec
charbour voilà les bêtes en train de
voilà en tout cas sur sur les
poissons sur le saumon les beaux
produits d'élevage et beaux poissons
d'élevage viennent de d'Écosse d'Irlande
c'est des produits qui sont labelllisés
oui donc on est sur une qualité
respectée sur un cahier des charges au
niveau de l'élevage qui est aussi
respecter qui est très clair que tout le
monde peut consulter donc on sait ce
qu'on comment c'est élevé ce qu'on va
manger exactement il y a de la
transparence transparence aussi au
niveau des élevages sur ces pointsl ça
c'est bien c'est c'est hein c'est c'est
un
oui c'est c'est très important
aujourd'hui de savoir d'où vient le
produit comment il a été traité alors
vous nous avez apporter voilà tout à
fait donc on a effectivement donc voilà
les saumons fumés qu'on qu'on tranche
également on est sur sur du saumon on va
mettre une bonne semaine à préparer du
saumon fumé ce qui est plutôt très long
comme cycle pour pour la fumaison de
poisson une semaine à partir du moment
où vous partez du saumon qui vous arrive
je récupère je récupère à partir du
moment où je vais lever les filets donc
le Fage la salaison avec un S de
euh qui vient de de guerandre on va
avoir une fumaison à la ficelle donc
avec des poissons qui sont suspendus
dans le fumoir et une étape qui est très
importante c'est un affinage une
maturation en chambre d'affinage donc où
les poissons vont passer 4 5 6 jours
alors je vous dis 4 5 6 ça dépend de de
pas mal beaucoup de paramètres c'est
pour ça qu'on est artisan parce qu'on a
plein de de paramètres à gérer qui sont
jamais les mêmes donc on va les voir
tous les jours les poissons c'est pas
c'est pas on sait celui-là c'est 6 jours
celui-là c'est 4 jours hein c'est il
faut regarder il faut il faut surveiller
il faut de gras
la météo à l'extérieur enfin beaucoup
beaucoup de paramètres qu'on peut pas
forcément maîtriser et doncon doit on
doit faire avec voilà m'exliquez qu'il
avit le fumage il y a aussi le séchage
alors le séchage ouis l'affinage le
séchage on va perdre beaucoup on va
faire sortir beaucoup d'eau des produit
pour concentrer le goût d'accord pour
éviter de trop saler nos produits pour
garder un vrai un vrai goût le vrai goût
du des poissons qu'on va qu'on va
travailler et puis éviter surtout cette
saturation en selle qui est un peu la
quand on achète dans les grand surface
par exemple enfin parfois c'est c'est
très salé c'est hein c'est vrai ouais
ouais beaucoup de saturationou pourquoi
parce que ça conserve non c'est ça c'est
la conservation qui on va avoir des gros
gros délis de conservation et ça évite
de faire sécher les poissons en fait ah
oui ah d'accord moi je perds je perd
entre 15 et 20 % du point de mes de mes
filets et oui il faut accepter ça et
faut il faut l'accepter moi j'accepte
mais voilà oui oui mais oui toutes les
il y a des voilà industrie voilà qui
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
c'est toujours mieux si on peut d'aller
bah chez un artisan comme comme Eric
hein euh alors donc vous avez là il y
avait le saumon fumé le saumon fumé donc
fait de la truite fumée donc ça c'est
c'est un copain moin cher du coup un
petit peu moins cher au kilo qui est
d'une qualité vraiment exceptionnelle
elle est délicieuse elle est vraiment
très très bonne c'est beaucoup moins
gras alors c'est pareil ça dépend d'où
ça vient moi je viens toujours je
travaille toujours avec le même
pisiculteur qui Normandie qui fait des
super poissons euh euh voilà et puis
après vous avez les prenez-les peut-être
comme ça on les verra mieux voilà on est
ver où non non devant vous devant vous
voilà bien comme ça donc les pavés de
Semon
fumé voilà donc c'est pareil on fait des
tranches des tranches aussi tout ça
c'est fait au couteau donc pour avoir
des tranches régulières c'est important
aussi euh et puis donc les produits je
vous ai apporté d'autres produits là de
de pêchei alors il il y pas que le
saumon voilà exactement il y a plein
d'autres choses vous avez de là mon
préféré c'est la sardine fumée donc
c'est des pêches françaises gni c'est
les mêmes techniques que sur du saumon
que sur de la truite c'est de la
salaison de la fumaison et et de
laffinage c'est vraiment très spécifique
pour chaque type de poisson pour chaque
poisson euh voilà ça sur une tartine de
pain beé c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique oui ça c'est vrai que oui on
peut dire voilà aux gens qui nous qui
nous regardent c'est très bien le saumon
c'est fort bien mais mais
voilà il y a d'autres choses il a il y a
pas que le saon dans la vie ouais ouais
VO même si c'est le produit phare et VO
c'est un produit phare les gens adorent
adorent ce produit donc on le fait la
sardine c'est formidable c'est
exceptionnel la SARD ouais hein puis on
fait du macro aussi qui estilà qui est
aussi très très bon qui sont aussi faut
dire des coups un peu moins exactement
on est sur des poissons bien moins
chers donc on arrive à avoir par rapport
au prix d'un saumon fumé être
pratiquement à la moitié du prix de oui
du saumon fumé c'est plein plein plein
de bonnes choses de plein d'Oméga
différent euh et puis ça varie enfin et
puis voilà on on va au lieu de voilà de
se contenter du du cabillot sur du
poisson cuit en cuisson et sur du saumon
en poisson fumé mais il y a plein
d'autres choses y a plein d'autres
choses voilà on comment dire on va la
pression va pas être sur un seul poisson
on va aller travailler sur plein
d'autres poissons il y a plein d'autres
poissons qui sont qui sont très bons euh
le macro la sardine vous avez le mulet
noir je vous parlais du mulet noir qui
une image qui est chez les cuisiniers
qui est très bonne mais ou monsieur tout
le
monde c'est c'est un poisson qui est
absolument merveilleux en cuisson mais
en fuma maison aussi
euh voilà il
y étendu il faut aller chez vous quoi
aller chez vous sur votre site
évidemment ou oui ben venir découvrir
tout ça et puis passer on a ouvert toute
l'année on mange du poisson fumé toute
l'année oui ça il y a évidemment on en
mange pour les fêes mais c'est vrai que
ça c'est quand j'étais quand j'étais
enfant on mangeait assez peu aujourd'hui
ça s quand même répondu c'est vrai même
le saum fumé quoi peut-être
malheureusement d'ailleurs ou oui c'est
malheureusementjet mais mais c'est un
vrai sujet peut-être que voilà il faut
c'est mieux de je pense que c'est
toujours mieux d'aller chez un
artisan que que voilà que dans une
grande surface mais mais moins mais
moins mais mieux
quoi tout à l'heure c'est ça ouais tout
à fait donc c'est c'est la fumerie du
coin c'est ça la fumerie du coin c'est
jou en et puis le vendredi le dimanche
sur le sur le marché de versaill et puis
il y a le site si vous fait FBR du coin
on trouve votre votre site exactement
avec toutes les informations vous êtes
un fumeur
heureux et en bonne santé et pas vous
êtes un fumeur actif
exactement alors on peut passer au
canard après avec plaisir oui avec
plaisir oui alors oui justement la ferme
du loup ravissant ravissant d'où ça
vient ça il y avait un
louput historiquement il y a eu un loup
oui en effet l'histoire ne le dit pas en
fait le le loup ravissant c'est le lieud
du du du du petit territoire du
territoire de basinville voilà
basinville c'est ça basinville donc et
donc le le lieud 10 s'appel le le loup
ravisant pour être pour être exact à
l'époque et pour ravisant avant d'être
ravant voilà c'est ça c'est ravisant
voilà en fait en
fait a priori oui serait une position du
loup qui est en attente un peu d'accord
en en chasse enfin voilà se ravise et
donc c'est devenu le l ravissant parce
que c'est un peu plus j j c'est c'est
magnifique comme comme comme moi alors
on nous le dit souvent moi c'est vrai
que je l'entends
tellement mais bon je suis ravi que ça
ça plaise ça plaise au consommateurs
alors dans dans dans la ferme on va
parler évidemment du du du canard mais
il y a il y a aussi des tomates des
courches des poireaux des pomes de
terre des salades des tomates des auberg
des courgettes enfin ouais c'est ça
ouais on a un atelier de de de maréchage
donc en direct donc plein champ souser
où on développe un panel de légumes le
le plus large possible ça c'est toute
l'année évidemment c'est toute l'année
et puis évidemment alors pour les fêes
mais bon enfin pour d'autres occasions
il y a il y a il y a tous les produits
autour du canard puisque vous avez un
élevage de de canard c'est ça donc toute
l'année on fait du canard gras sauf
juilletaoût et puis un peu au mois de
janvier où on se repose euh mais sinon
toute l'année on on élève du des canards
on les transforme chez nous en fait le
circuit il est extrêmement court parce
que ils arrivent en caneton à la ferme
et puis et puis on les on les élève
pendant 120 jours en en extérieur dans
dans leur parcours oui c'est ça ils sont
totalement à l'extérieur ça voilà on on
les rentre la nuit parce que à cause du
loup ravisant il il reste des renards en
tout cas il y a plus de loup mais il
reste des renard oui il y a des petits
prédateurs quand même c'est ça donc donc
on est obligé de les r t les tout à fait
et puis bon ça nous permet aussi d'être
toujours d'avoir l'œil sur sur nos
animaux tous les jours soir quoi et et
donc on on les élève jusqu'à 120 jours
on les engresse pendant 13 jours les 13
derniers jours de le leur vie et on les
abat chez nous parce qu'on a l'abattoir
agréer on a on a le laboratoire de
transformation agréer de découpe agréer
voilà comme ça on fait tout de A à Z et
et tout t produits évidemment le maïs
que vous leur donnez alors le maïs c'est
un voisin qui qui qui qui fait plus de
maïs que moi qui qui me le produit parce
que voilà c'est assez technique aussi le
maïs faut pas qu'il sèche trop vite donc
si je faisais un maïs que j'emmenais à
la coopérative et il faut une une
certaine variété de maïs aussi donc
voilà c'est un faut vraiment être faut
vraiment être carré là-dessus euh donc
c'est une variété de
maïne la qualité après du produit quoi
c'est ça qui faut que ça sèche lentement
pour pas dégrader la Midon du maïs pour
qu'il soit plus assimilable pour pour
les volailles voilà pour les volailles
oua et euh donc ça évidemment ça donne
ça donne beaucoup de produits euhit vous
apporter tout voilà donc évidemment le
foie gras parce que c'est avant tout
entre guillemets ce à quoi sert no nos
canards mais comme il y a du fois grave
frais voilà il y a un foi cru frais qui
est là voilà donc ça c'est comm ça qu'on
le présente
euh comme on on a on a les gens
maintenant ils se sont mis de plus en
plus à faire le le le propr oui al ils
ont tous ils ont tous leur leur recette
familiale ah je dirais pas l'alcool que
je mets dedans par que c'est Mar C
famille mais très bien et et on est ravi
que chacun a sa recette nous on a quand
on goûte c'est un peu comme le le saumon
et oh c'est trop
salé nous on a en tout en toute modest
on a réussi à trouver un juste équilibre
entre entre tous
les ou enfin c'est très bien non c'est
très bien de le faire
soi-même ça nous permet aussi de de de
proposer
C sinon il y en a que vous avez c'est ça
on propose alors on propose trois gammes
de de fois gras donc celui qu'on a amené
là là le fois gras mitui cuisiné en en
tiine porcelaine euh où là on a juste
foie gras c'est le poivre et un peu
d'alcool pour l'aromatiser euh on a le
foie gras m cuit en bocal où là c'est
juste foie grass et le poivre et on a le
foie gras entier en conserve où là c'est
juste foie grass et le poivre la
différence entre le M cuuit et la
conserve c'est évidemment le temps de
cuisson et la température de cuisson le
micuuit est cuit à 65 à 75°gr et le
l'entier conserve à 105° d'accord donc
pour le Miku on est plutôt sur une
pasteurisation alors que sur l'entier
conserve on est vraiment sur une
stérilisation
qui qui souvent la question qu'on me
pose c'est ah oui mais ma femme est
enceinte je techniquement il y a pas de
problème c'est Cu à 75 degr pendant 1 he
et3 donc voilà ah oui on a peur de de
quoi bah des des des problèmes liés à la
viande qui est pas assez cuite quoi pour
les pour les mais nous on on est on est
dans les il y a eu des problèmes de
grippe aviaire gripe aviaire ouais on a
subi pendant un an alors pas directement
chez chez nous mais mais elle a été
foudroyante hein C cetteière à tel point
que
euh les les couvoirs donc ceux qui nous
distribuent les canetons euh ont dû
arrêter euh pendant un lapse de temps de
de de distribuer des canetons parce que
déjà il y avait des restrictions de
transport et euh parce qu'ils ont dû
abattre aussi une partie des chepteles
reproducteurs donc les mâles et les
femelles qui font des des œufs pour
voilà donc du coup quasiment pendant 1
an euh on n pas eu de caneton on n' pas
pu produire bon voilà on avait un peu de
stock mais euh on est arrivé à fin juin
2023 où on av av quasiment écoulé tout
le stock donc fallait reprendre alors on
a repris les l'élevage à partir de mai
pardon mai
2023 pour pour les premiers abattages
fin août 2023 d'accord et oui évidemment
c'est une crainte ah c'est une épée de
damoclass qu'on a toute l'année he
souvent souvent là là en plus ce qui se
passe avec les périodes migratoires donc
à partir de novembre souvent là c'est on
croise les doigts pour pas qu'on ait de
problème donc ça revient un petit peu là
mais en fait fait il y a une gripe av
tellement foudroyante que que les
autorités sanitaires ont mis le ont mis
le paquet pour sortir précaution aussi
et puis et puis et puis trouver des
vaccins et trouver des vaccins oui oui
c'est ça il y a des vaccins ils ont
sorti voilà depuis quelques temps des
vaccins contre les gavière donc il y a
tout un programme un processus à mettre
en place ils ont démarré les campagnes
de vaccination donc moi je vais pas
tarder voilà pour pour certains lots
commencer à les vacciner pour en tout
cas pas qu'elle se diffuse c'est ça ça
oui alors la priorité euh dans les
premiers dans les premiers échos c'était
de de vacciner les reproducteurs h parce
qu'en fait il y avait un cooup du vaccin
quand même donc enendrer enfin
répercuter un coup de vaccin sur un
caneton ça aurait été un petit peu un
petit peu compliqué alors que sur les
producteurs qui eux vont potentiellement
faire pluson voilà c'était un peu plus
un peu plus logique bon visiblement
visiblement il y aura quand même des
campagnes de vaccination chez les
éleveurs et bon si ça nous permet de de
de maintenir not
activité fa on le prend coup ouis c'est
un coup mais c'est pris plus ou moins en
charge c'est mieux c'est mieux d'avoir
un coup et d'avoir une production bah
c'est ça ouais que que de ne pas rien
produire pendant un an
quoi euh alors on on a des fois gr le ça
c'est c'est sousv alors voilà c le FO
gramui comme ça cuisiné en terine
porcelaine il est mis sous vide il a une
DLC d'un mois et tient au frais il se
maintient au frais et ça c'est ça marche
très très bien pour les fait il y a
juste l'avantage du souv comme ça c'est
que euh nous quand on les cuit donc dans
l'autoclave quand on les sort on les
presse comme ça le gras il sort un petit
peu de la terrine et donc ça nous permet
de d'enlever le maximum de gras et
proposer souvent le problème enfin
souvent ça nous arrive que en conserve
une fois qu'on met toujours par exemple
pour un bocal de 100 g on va mettre 120
125 presque 130 g de matière parce que
le foie ça fond c'est toujours un peu
pareil le le la bête noire du foie gras
c'est de fondre à la cuisson donc on met
toujours on essaie de charger au maximum
nos conserves pour
limiter enfin qui reste un maximum de
fois gras il pas trop de gras mais la
conserve une fois qu'elle est sertie on
ne peut plus y toucher donc une fois
qu'elle est sertie qu'elle est mis dans
l'autoclave on a pu mettre de de du Tau
de fond quoi donc c'est pour ça qu'il y
a toujours un peu moins de gras dans
dans un mitui parce que il est cuit à 4
75°gr que dans une conserve mais
l'avantage de de la terine sous vide
c'est que là on enlève le gras aprèsfin
on peut enlever le gras après
pr on le laisse refroidir comme ça le
gras fige et euh voilà quand on le
démoule on enlève le l'enleverou ah oui
donc ça fait un produit ça fait un
produit où il y a moins de gras al que
dans une conserve potentiellement vous
pouvez acheter un peu de gras bon après
les cuisiniers les cuisiniers qui qui
qui aiment cuisiner ils conserve le gras
et puis cuisine avec le gras c'est on
vend on vend des bocos simplement avec
de la graisse parce que il y a des
cuisiniers qui qui cuisinent petite
pommme de TERC l'ardaise revenu à la
graisse de de canard et la graisse de
canard est une excellente graisse
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui cuisinent oui
VI
la graisse can ou il y a rien de mie
Laurent vous faites du FO au restaurant
oui celui de jefrey oui cel bien sûr
ou et je le fais on l'achète en l'obacc
FA
et alors après il y a d'autres produits
il y a par exemple les riettes de canard
c'est ça alors comme on a enfin on est
quand même souciux un petit peu de de ce
qu'on fait on en jette le le minimum à
la poubelle en quelque sorte donc on
valorise on essaie de valoriser tout la
toute la viande du canard donc
évidemment les Magris que qu'on fend s
vide à l'umité les aiguillettes alors
aiguillettes c'est un tout petit filet
de de viande qui est entre la carcassé
le magret qui est très subtile les
cuisses qu'on valorise en confit ou
alors évidemment bah oui ou alors en
chourout on a une recette de choucrout
de lentill voilà de cassoulet au confit
de canard Chout au canard chourout au
confit de canard ouais c'est extra faut
goûter c'est c'est c'est extra et
évidemment bah avec tout le reste de la
viande bah on fait des riettes 100 %
canard où on rajoute on rajoute même un
un peu de gras de canard parce que sinon
elles sont un peu trop sèches mais on ne
rajoute pas de gras de porc donc
potentiellement c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui ce qui peut faire des riettes un
petit peu ch grass moins grass que des r
des rillettes de porort en général ou
même des rillettes de canard qu'on
trouve dans je dirais de industriel ou
il rajoute un petit peu deort bah parce
que ça coûte beaucoup moins cher
pourcentage de GR il en fait il y a une
réglementation quand même à à respecter
sur sur les riettes ou pour avoir
l'appellation l'appellation riette de
canard c'est faut qu'il a au moins 23 %
de ah d'accord il me semble que c'est 23
% de de viande de canard nous laiss 100
% voilà ça c'est on se pose pas de
question on se pose pas de question
voilà là encore oui c'est ça l'avantage
d'aller alors évidemment il y a une
boutique l ravissant tris routes de
rbourg à basaville qui est ouverte je
crois moi j'ai vu que c'était le
mercredi le vendredi après-midi samedi
le matin c'est ça alors en période tout
ça c'est c'est nos horaires de toute
l'année ou en période de fête voilà
évidemment on est ouvert un peu plus
régulièment
d'accord les crneau juste avant Noël
justement après on pe vous avez un site
aussi hein donc il est en construction
mais il y a a P faceb il y a un numéro
de téléphone il y a aucun problème où il
y a tout les horaires sur sur sur le
répondeur et il y a le voilà le facebook
de la ferme du L vissant où il y a
toutes les informations également très
bien c'est génial hein c'est génial
c'est c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est un
Liu magnifique et vous êtes donc le
dernier producteur de FO dans les
evelines ouais c'est ça ou des evelines
mais il y a du FO des evelines voilà
mais il y en a quasiment plus non plus
en î de France quoi en valdoise il y en
a plus dans les sommes il y en a il doit
en rester un
tout alors peut-être que le métier in
gras peut-être que B en fait c'est un
petit peu je dirais comme ENF ça reste
un élevage donc il y a besoin de d'être
présent quasiment tout le temps une
prophylaxie à à suivre et puis c'est un
peu je DIRIS c'est un peu comme le lait
c'est-à-dire que pour l'engraissement
c'est matin et soir ça ouanée donc en
fait et puis c'est tôt le matin jusqu'à
potentiellement tard le soir donc en
fait il y a des contraintes horires qui
qui sont qui sont là aussi après moi
j'ai j'ai pris le parti de
de de pas de continuer l'activité parce
qu'il y a un super savoir-faire c'est
oui ça commenence en
87 voilà
vousexpérience et puis c'est quand même
un des fleurons de la gastronomie
française le FO qu'on se le dise il y a
un savoir-faire il il y a une zone de
chalandise comme
disait notre ami de qui est énorme l'-
de France donc donc voilà c'est un peu
un Paris et puis et puis on y va hein
faut ben bravo merci bravo donc voilà la
ferme du loup ravissant à
basinville et puis donc il y a la
boutique où on peut aller acheter des
des produits ça c'est vous VZ que chez
vous alors non non on a des partenaires
revendeurs beaucoup dans les Yvelines
quelquesuns à Paris voilà on vend
également des des des produits de de de
nos confrères producteur éleveur ou
voilà l'objectif voilà nous nos produits
euh enfin j'ai j'ai j'ai pris le parti
prix de
de de de donner l'exclusivité à soit des
des producteurs des des fermes
cuillettes ou des des producteurs
collègues ou aux épiceries fines j'ai
été démarché par des grandes surfaces
moi aujourd'hui c'est voilà c'est pas un
créneau c'est pas un créneau que que que
que je veux prendre pour pas dévaloriser
notre produit parce qu'en fait
aujourd'hui typiquement une rillette 100
% canard en grande surface si elle est
mise à côté d'une riette euh de d'un
d'un industriel les gens vont la trouver
trop cher donc ils vont en fait ils vont
me cataloguer tout de suite en trop cher
alors que c'est pas du tout le même
produ pas le même produit VO donc donc
oui ça s'appelle riette mais ça n'a rien
à voir c'est ça l les étiquettes
exactement bah oui oui mais euh les
enfin le consommateur il il voit le prix
et puis c'est tout quoi il s'arrête là
et puis ça permet aussi de de de de de
donner un un je veux dire une
exclusivité à certains à certains à
certains un certains vendeurs qui vont
valoriser un peu mieux nos nos produits
quoi très bien génial merci merci à vous
on va parler fromage alors après on a
fait le poisson le le le foie gras et et
le canard fromage avec Ludovic bisou euh
donc tout un fromage c'est ça tout un
fromage à à rembouiller alors vous vous
avez un un itinéraire absolument
incroyable euh c'està dire que vous ah
bah si vous avez fait des études de
commerce vous étiez consultant stratégie
hein au cadre supérieur quoi dans dans
dans l'industrie et puis eu à quel âge
43 ans je crois hein vous dites mais
vous aviez une passion pour le fromage
déjà très jeune hein j' avis une grande
passion pour le fromage je voulais
absolument que le fromage ait une place
pas que dans ma vie privée dans ma vie
professionnelle et comme on a qu'une vie
et bien j'ai fait en sorte de de mettre
le fromage dans ma vie pour la la oui la
deuxième partie de mon parcours
professionnel c'est ça et c'est donc ça
c'est en 2009 c'est ça c'est ça oui donc
vous ouvrez tout un fromage à
rembouiller je reprends une petite
boutique a des gens qui partaient à la
retraite qui était déjà bien établ et je
la rebaptise tout un fromage en 2010
effectivement voilà et alors c'est pas
fini si je peux dire parce que en
2013 vous
dites pourquoi je passerais pas le le
concours de meilleurs ouvriers de France
oui je me dis que bah je suis ma passion
est intacte et j'ai besoin d'un
aiguillon pour continuer à travailler à
progresser à orer et pour pas passer du
côté d'une petite routine qui pourrait
être la routine du petit commerce voilà
et donc je je m'inscris au concours et
après comme je suis un compétiteur j'ai
fait j'ai fait ce qu'il faut pour c'est
c'est c'est très compliqué il faut dire
oui oui c'est un concours d'excellence
il y a quoi il y a 13 épreuves je crois
c'est ça c'est ça il y a 13 épreuves en
plusieurs phases qui font le tour de
tous les savoir-faire autour de notre
métier quoi quoi par exemple comme
épreuve bah vous avez
minable nous
non vous avez pu on connaît ça dans le
vin vous avez une épreuve de dégustation
à l'aveveugle vous faut reconnaître le
fromage et donner son âge ah oui alors
en qcm he pas mais vous on vous demande
si tel produit il a 6 mois 10 mois et
cetera euh vous avez des épreuves de
composition artistique de présentation
de mise en valeur parce que notre métier
de crémier fromager n'est pas un métier
de fabrication contrairement à mes
camarades ici mais c'est un métier
d'expertise de sélection de maîtrise de
l'affinage et de mise en valeur du
produit et alors vous êtes fromag
affineur hein on dit aussi non c'est ça
oui affineur c'est-à-dire que alors je
personne n'est complètement affineur
dans le sens où dans une boutique où
vous avez 100 ou 150 fromages personne
ne peut prétendre à affiner sur place
tous ces produits donc l'affinage pour
pour moi c'est une compétence mais qui
s'applique à une partie de notre gamme
où on on rentre des fromages à un état
plus jeune qu'on va faire mûir d'accord
et qu'on va faire évoluer plutôt crémeux
plutôt plus sec
aromatisé humidifié par un brossage et
cetera des soins d'affinage mais ça ne
concerne pas tous les produits je prends
un exemple très clair le compé il il
s'affine très très bien dans ces
immenses caves cathédrales en Fran
compté je reçois des meules de compté
prête à être coupé pour M VO
Laou avant chez vous porter avant chez
vous ça ser à rien ça serait ça serait
puisquil il s'affine très bien tout
çaine très bien chez les spécialistes
absolument un mot sur la c'est parce que
une question un peu de beussi mais je me
suis toujours posé comment vous
conservez les fromages dans une
fromagerie parce que moi quand quand je
mets des fromages chez moi par exemple
je les mets au frigo après ils sont ils
sont moins
bons comment on
fait disons que chez vous chez les
particuliers on n pas les bonnes
conditions pour conserver le fromage
parce que le frigo c'est un peu trop
froid et la cave qu'on peut avoir
éventuellement sous la maison c'est un
peu trop chaud parce que si on met pas
dedans la la bonne fenêtre c'est c'est
entre 6 et 10°gr d'accord donc les fr
donc vous avez des des donc on a des des
installations des chambres avec de
l'affinage de l'humidité et une
température régulée pour bien conserver
les produits et ensuite on va jouer sur
la ventilation la protection ou pas des
produits par rapport au flux d'air voilà
et donc effectivement mon message c'est
n'essayez pas à la maison de conserver
très longtemps les fromages vaut mieux
acheter moins mais plus souvent
absolument non mais moi c'est c'est vrai
que c'est c'est c'est le conseil qu'il
faut donner parce que c'est il est
meilleur quand on quand on le sort de
chez le fromager qu'on le mange après
pour quelques jours hein oui après voilà
on peut le garder un peu mais mais trop
longtemps c'est pas c'est pas terrible
quoi c'est pas terrible alors j'ai vu
qu'il y avait on va parler après des des
des fromages que vous avez apporté mais
j'ai vous que j'ai vu il il y a un Briis
des ivelines alors oui nous avons dans
les Yvelines une belle fabrication de
fromage alors c'est on n'est pas une
grande région de fromagein de là mais
nous avons un très beau producteur dans
le sud des Yvelines qui s'appelle la
ferme de la tremblae à la Boissière
école limitrophe heuréloire ouis avec un
élevage de vache et de chèvr d'accord et
de très bons produits dans un dont un
Briolet cru
un petit BR fermier fermier comme donc
Le Roch av raison d on trouve tous les
produitsveage dans fromage dans
lesvelines et puis celui qu'on trouve
pas dans les evvelines on peut venir
l'acheter à tout un fromageouiller alors
vous avez porté alors ça c'est des
fromages que vous conseillez un peu pour
les fêtes ou pour la pour la saison en
tout cas oui ce sont des fromages que je
conseille pour la saison et une saison
pour les fromages il y a une saisonalité
pour le fromage soit une saisonalité
complète pour quelques produits on
connaitt le Mondor qui n'est disponible
en automne hiver et la saisonnalité des
fromage c'est plutôt une petite
sinusoïde qui fait que selon la période
de production le le lait est moins moins
riche moins aromatique et donc le
fromage peut être un peu meilleur quand
il est produit notamment avec de lait à
partir d'herbes quand les animaux sont
nourris à l'herbe ah d'accord ah oui il
faut que oui et ça vous savez aussi d'
d'où viennent enfin oui bien oui on
connaitt nos producteurs on leur rend
visite on suit l'évolution des produits
sur le cycle de l'année évidemment vous
avez qu'un producteur par fromage ou
vous avez
plusieursp ça dépend dans la plupart des
cas oui et dans certains cas j'ai un
producteur et un pas une roue de secours
maisueur oui un coproducteur un deuxème
choix parce que effectivement certains
produits sont pas tout à fait régulier
ou disponible toute l'année mais c'est
c'est aussi le charme des produits
fermiers le pro d'un produit fermier
c'est qu'il n'est pas toujours tou
homogène au cordau toute l'année d'où
l'importance de venir dans dans par
exemple chez vous he il y en a d'autres
éidemment et d'avoir les conseils les
conseils de de voilà du fromager hein
c'est important alors euh bah peut-être
je vous laisse décrire les que vousz
alors je précise quand même puisque on a
suivi un peu la séquence du REP c'est
très bien mais qu'on peut aussi on a le
droit de commencer par le fromage à
savoir qu'el apéritif le fromage et
particulièrement moi je j'adore ça parce
qu'on a les papilles et l'appétit
entièrement disponible et on apprécie
particulièrement le fromage quand on
commence par lui alors c'est un peu une
façon de tirer la couverture à nous mais
mais voilà n'hésite je commencerai par
vous voilà bah retenez cette petite
formule retenez cette formule voilà un
apéro sans fromage c'est trop dommage
met du fromage à la non c'est vrai que
c'est une bonne très bonne idée et bien
iciage par exemple comme fromage ah ben
on peut PRS tout selon deux modalités
soit les fromages à P dur qu'on va
couper en petit CUB en petit fr qu'on
prend à la main ou bien ou bien
l'inverse presque le côté on tartine du
coulant du
crémeux Marcelin du du Gor gonzola du
roquefort tout ça peut se tartiner sur
des petits toastes je crois qu'on disait
d'Ille le le le le le
[Musique]
le le Rockfort par exemple avec du du
Porou je crois que c'est c'est oui les
les les pâtes persillé notamment les
plus puissants se marient très bien avec
des vins un petit peu sucrés sucrés hein
c'est ça oui les les musc Moris Porto et
ce oui alors alors ici bah c'est une une
sélection pour les fêtes mais qui n'a
rien de
d'imposé un exemple où j'ai repris
quelques quelquesuns de mes coups de
cœur on va commencer par les
Yvelines puisque notre ferme de la
tremblae qui don on parlait tout à
l'heure avec leur bris vient de sortir
un nouveau produit que je trouve
magnifique et très réussi alors vous
allez deviner son nom quand on voit son
aspect il s'appelle le pavé de Paris et
c'est
simplement pour le faire ils sont sont
baladés un jour dans Paris ils ont pris
un pavé sur un
chantier ils l'ont ramené à la ferme et
ils ont travaillé longtemps pour avoir
cette croûte cette texture cette couleur
qui imite exactement la forme de du pavé
parisien ah c'est magnifique ça ça c'est
la croûte hein alors ça c'est la croûte
et à l'intérieur ben on le coupe en
petit cube voilà et c'est un mélange en
fait de vaches et de chèvr mais c'est
pas un mélange de lait c'est un mélange
de C c'estàdire un stade ultérieur ce
qui fait qu'on a des marbrures jaunes et
blanches parce qu'on a agrégé de cahiers
le le cahier de chèvre a tendance à être
plus blanc et le cahier de vache un
petit peu plus jaune donc un magnifique
fromage voilà avec une belle pas pas
très connu donc pas très connu parce
qu'il est à la fois nouveau mais il est
promis un bel avenir moi je l'adore
gustativement il est très réussi il est
amusant je suis sûr qu'il va faire c'est
une B très belle idée il va faire un
carton ensuite
ben on va rester en île-de-fance avec un
BRI de maot garni à la truffe oui alors
ça c'est le mais c'est bien la truve
dans le fromage oui c'est bien à petite
dose he moi pas trop moi j'ai deux
produits sur 150 fromage et deux
produits à la truffe pour en proposer
mais je suis pas voilà je suis pas parce
que je trouve un moment c'est devenu la
mode la truffe quoi oui oui c'est c'est
parfois c'est un petit peu trop et on se
met à truffer Desages n avec la truff
quoi oui c'est pas la peine deper de
l'argent pour ououi on va bientôt avoir
de la truffe au le BR magnif oui alors
le BR le Briis c'est magnifique ça peut
être aussi le bris à savarin des
fromages qui ont cette onctuosité ce
crémeux qu'on vient garnir dans leur
milieu avec un mélange de crème type
mascarpone et des lamelles de truff et
donc là c'est un voilà c'est un beau
produit festif produit de fait VO pour
le coup euh ensuite et bien on va aller
en Bourgogne moi je suis bourguignon de
naissance donc je je fais rarement la
plateau de fromage chez moi sans fromage
de Bourgogne c'est un petit fromage
magnifique à croûte lavée que j'adore
qui s'appelle le fermier au chaeli
fromage de vache lavé au Chabeli et on
boit du chabel avec ou pas alors on peut
on on pour reparler du vin avec le
fromage on peut boire du blanc ou un
rouge léger mais effectivement si on
déguste ce fromage avec un vin autant
aller sur un blanc
typ oui on peut on peut boire du vin
blanc avec les fromages ah oui oui oui
oui il y a un fort consensus d'ailleurs
des someliers des onologue restaurateur
sur le blanc avec le fromage donc ça
c'est le fermier au CH un petit fromage
qui avait disparu qu'on a ressuscité
avec son affineur Pascal lerou dans
Lyonne un bleu que j'apprécie
particulièrement qui est très élégant
subtile dans son persillage comme dans
son goût qui s'appelle la fourme de
Monbrison on est qui n'est pas la fourme
d'Amber qui est une autre forme
d'appellation et qui Monbrison c'est pas
c'est pas Montbrison c'est donc dans la
Loire c'est à la frontière entre le
massif central et puis la le le le
Lyonnais et c'est un très joli bleu et
pour évoquer les ivelines j'aime bien
penser que son persillage très fin comme
ça bleu un peu clair pour moi il évoque
la toile de joui donc c'est c'est voilà
c'est on revient on revient à l'umerie
du
coin
et enfin à tout seigneur tout honneur le
compté he produit phare noble excellent
s'il en est qu'est-ce qu'il faut prendre
il faut prendre quoi du du affiner
depuis alors ici je vous ai proposé un
compté affiné 30 mois 30 mois c'est le
plus non c'est pas le plus on peut
toujours faire plus mais après parce
qu'on trouve quoi 12 18 30 ah bah on
trouve tous les mois poss possible hein
ça dépend quand il a été fabriqué plus
plus de moi d'affinage plus il est fort
c'est ça oui il devient plus puissant
plus boucané éventuellement plus salé
moi je considère que le compté passé 3
ans c'est c'est excellent mais ça
devient un autre produit c'est autre
chose les notes typiques du compté
s'exprime vraiment jusqu'à 30 30 36 mois
après ça devient aut chose ou donc là on
a 30 mois un produit fabriqué donc au
printemps 2021 affiné aux force Antoine
ah oui près de Pontarlier et euh et là
on a la plénitude on a les petits
cristaux de protéines qui font ce petit
croquant sous la dent et des arômes
voilà très très expressifs très longs
voilà il en parle bien
hein rentre ch vous avez vous avez un
bar à fromage non vous on a eu un bar à
fromage oui mais mais aujourd'hui on a
une table à fromage que quand les gens
rentrent dans le restaurant il y a le T
les fromages chouloch ou tout à fait
tous les fromages je je précise que j'en
ai vu pas mal des restaurants j'en sers
un certain nombre euh chez Laurent
trochin on a un des plus beaux service
du fromage qu'on puisse trouver en
restauration gastronomique en France ah
ah oui ou c'est
magnifique c'est vous qui dit parce
qu'on aime c'est parce qu'on aime le
fromage
c'est
absolument on parlait des un mot des des
vin avec le avec le fromage avec le avec
le foie gras
d'ailleurs
après
c'estux évidemment mais moi
personnellement je suis pas trop trop
fan après c'est une question ça va très
bien a aussi non ais c'est quand même
d'ordinaire c'est plutôt du du blanc
quand
même du demise ça va très bien mais
moi chacun chacun oui qu'il aime avec
produit le sa plutôt plutôt sur des
blanc blanc aussi hein ouais Chab très
bien chbl oui ch du saumon au
fromage vous faites un accord mes vin
oui oui oui c'est mon c'est mon épouse
Julie qui qui s'occupe de ça ouis accord
mes vin ou accord mes jus de fruit aussi
parce que ça plaît beaucoup oui
parce ouais bien sûr ouis non mais il y
a les deux c'est vrai qu'on peut voilà
et après c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les
codes ont changé hein voilà avant
c'était vraiment toujours le vin
licoreux avec le foie gras aujourd'hui
on est plus sur un vin sec avant c'était
le vin rouge avec age maintenant mais
tout s'exlique aussi et tout a évolué
comme comme tout évolué je veux dire
aujourd'hui on est plus libre
aujourd'hui hein il y a plus de liberté
et puis voilà on a le droit d'avoir des
des goûs différents et absolument et et
c'est vrai que oui le le le alors sa
c'est un d'exception évidemment mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas forcément en
fait c'est c'est licoreux on estjà sur
un qui est grave remettre
uniss ça c'est ça fait un peu ouais moi
le FO gras je vote pour le vioner ah
c'est magnifique blanc aromatique mais
pas mais pas non plus sucré c'est très
bon le vionier et c'est un peu moins
cher que le le que d'autres aut V le je
sais plus enfin c'est très bon le
et avec le chocolat et l' cololat ah oui
moi je recommande plutôt le
thé parce que le chocolat pour que ça
fonde en bouche il faut une boisson
quand même même plutôt une boîte son
chaude de façon à ce que le gras fonde
rapidement dans la bouche et donne ses
arômes donc moi je suis plutôt pour une
boisson chaude une tisane ou un thé ou
c'est pas mal hein parce que ça fait oui
ça fait fondre le le chocolat dans la
bouche oui alors euh la la maison Cola
euh vous disiez vous allez fêter vos 50
ans en septembre prochain septembre
prochain en train de se creuser la tête
pour savoir comment fêter ça dignement
parce queon avait déjà fait
les 40
ans en faisant toute une rétrospective
sur l'année de tous les produits phar de
chaque année c'està-dire qu'on avait
fait des petites stelles dans la
boutique et à chaque fête à l'automne à
Noël à la Saint-Valentin à P on avait
réédité les produits phar de chaque
année donc là c'était intéressant puis
c'était un travail un petit peu
d'archive et puis on av on a toujours
les premiers chocolatiers les les deux
premiers apprentis de papa qui sont avec
nous ah oui donc qui ont la mémoire qui
connaissent tout ce qui s'est passé dans
la maison donc on avait pu faire ça donc
là pour les 50 ans il va falloir trouver
une autre idée on ira tous en septembre
à moule hein voir pour voir que pour
voir qu quelle idée vous avez eu alors
vous êtes vous êtes venu avec un un
trésor oui hein un coffre à trésor
coffre voilà euh ça c'est c'est le c'est
ce que vous proposez pour les pour les
fêtes alors c cette année les et c'est
ce sont les chocolatiers qui avaient
très envie de faire un thème sur les
pirates et puis donc on on fait filer ce
thème sur toute l'année à la rentrée
nous avons travaillé sur retour des
Caraïbes le chocolat qui vient des
Caraïbes bien sûr donc les chocolats
d'Amérique centrale qui sont les
chocolats les plus renommés les plus
aromatiques fruités acidulé florau aux
arômes et puis
ensuite donc les on a fait les pirates
pour Halloween et là pour Noël les
pirates ont trouvé le trésor et donc
nous avons réalisé des des pierres
précieuses en
chocolat c'est des pierres délicieuses
oui c'est des pierres précieuses et
délicieuses oui voilà donc nous avons
des du chocolat non alors ça c'est de la
pâte de fruit de la ferme du logie à
jumoville d'accord euh on a des pralinés
sarrasin des des pâte de
d'amande de des pralinées amandes pâte
de d'orange
g sèon qui a pris la forme deistau c'est
magnifique alors là c'est la collection
pour cette fin d'année on renouvelle nos
produits tous les de TR mois euh nous en
fait quand comme on existe depuis 50 ans
que notre clientèle c'est 20 km à la
ronde ça nous ça nous oblige à beaucoup
renouveler nos nos nos propositions
parce que faut pas lasser les clients
alors on propose toujours évidemment les
petit chocolat traditionnel on a
gardé la collection une boî no petits
chocolat
euh pour
certains ce sont des chocolats que papa
faisait déjà au tout début d'accord on a
les trois petites noisettees caramélisé
là qui sont vraiment produits
phar ça vous tente allez on y va oh
merci merci beaucoup
allez la petites noisettes caramélisée
en Robé de chocolat merci merci noisette
pimonaz et ah ben ça vous dit ou bah oui
je bon moi je parle alors et et donc on
a nos petit chocolat traditionnel et moi
ce que j'ai apporté dans l'entreprise
c'est en fait le le travail visuel
puisque j'ai une formation initiale en
design on a rappliqué ah voilà donc j'ai
travaillé d'abord un petit peu dans
design avec mon mari et enensite suite
quand mes parents on envisagé de prendre
leur retraite ça pas été possible je
suis revenu au berkaille vite fait bien
fait c'estable qu' soit resté dans la
famille quoi et j'ai
appliqué que j'avais appris au chocolat
c'est-à-dire la création de moule la
création de
colleue ex la long vue du
pirate peux sortir ça on peut tout
sortir voilà la bouteille à la
mer donc avec une illustration qui est
réalisée tout au AC des pigments
alimentaires et beurre de cacao donc là
c'est un travail de peintre dans
l'équipe j'ai une jeune femme qui a un
DMA d'art plastique qui se demandait un
peu comment elle allait gagner sa vie
avec cette formation et une amie commune
nous a présenté et elle est maintenant
spécialiste de la peinture sur chocolat
magifque coucher comme ça là faut la
coucher voilà le bateau oui le bateau
voilà sublime donc voilà c'est c'est
c'est notre touche c'est notre pâte par
rapport à à la formation les
chocolatiers c'est pas le type
d'esthétique que l'on apprend en école
de chocolaterie donc ça ça nous ça nous
permet d'avoir une identitéent
différente absolument ouavoir notre
identité c'estd que c'est à la fois voà
vous conciliez le le le la qualité du
produit parce que c'est je vi de goûter
là c'est magnifique quand même he avec
avec oui le design avec la présentation
avec oui c'est c'est de l'art quoi on
s'amuse avec la matière euh le chocolat
c'est vraiment un produit qui est
agréable à travailler qui se met en
forme qui au niveau des goûts permet
beaucoup d'association beaucoup de
fantaisie beaucoup
de une palette aromatique aussi très
très large donc c'est vraiment une
matière avec
laquelle on peut vraiment se faire
plaisir décler
suser évidemment votre votre maison
c'est vrai qu'on a on a de on est un
pays de grand chocolatier hein oui euh
les les choco c'est en France qu'on
déguste les chocolats les plus typés les
moins sucrés oui vous avez beaucoup de
confrères envoyé de France d'ailleurs
dans les dans les chocolat
c'est vrai que c'est on est on est très
bon quoi mais en fait on a le un peu le
palais du vin justement du fromage et ce
qui qui aussi permet de déguster les
chocolats de façon
ouais c'est subtile bah c'est
merveilleux tout
ça merci Laurent parce que vous avez
fait découvrir c'est normal on voit bien
que dans les ibines on aou on a des
produits merveilleux et des artisans
merveilleux parce que moi moi tous les
ans au mois de décembre tous les jours
j'ai mon chocolat Cola avec mon
calendrier de l'avand
calendri on a pas parlé mais parce qu'on
est oui c'est presque un peu tard mais
un calendrier de l'avanceou bien sû ben
ça y est tout est vendu hein on n pas
cherché le calendrier donc
oui c'est ça c'est non c'est d'autant
plus plus gentil d'être venu que comme
er comme vous voil vous avez pas besoin
de enfin vous avez toujours besoin de
client vousêt plutôt plutôt suroccupé
actuellement C
jour on les a laissé qu'il se
débrouillent on verra tout à l'HE on va
dire à nos clients venez après venez
aussi après les
film un calendrier de l'après voilà ça
serait bien un calendrier de l'après ou
sur toute l'année jusqu'à début décembre
non c'est c'est c'est merveilleux euh
d'où alors vous disiez voilà tous ces
produitsvin d'où l'importance du guolin
euh que donc que que vous allez que vous
avez vous avez eu l'idée euh on on se
reverra en janvier ouis bien sûr si vous
êtes d'accord parce que à partir de
janvier ça va ça va ça va se lancer
puisque il faut que on va par tout soit
prêt avant avant les quoi voilà tout à
fait là là pour l'instant l'important
c'est de de référencer sur le site
internet tous les artisans les éleveurs
les producteurs des ivblines en fait
voilà d'accord alors je je ne suis pas
du
tout cuisinier comme vous mais je me
suis un peu initié on a fait on a fait
une petite une petite émission avec
Véronique lecamu avec une une jeune
femme qui s'appelle Charlotte Martin et
qui qui vient chez vous pour vous faire
des des faire faire des pâtes ou faire
des pâtes si vous voulez alors on
diffusera l'émission dans dans quelques
dans quelques temps voilà je vous
propose une petite bande annonce une
boule et on
va fa faire une
Bou ça faire des patri ça ce sera unres
la prochaine fois c'est pom de TER on
est
d'accord on peut en faire avec
[Musique]
d' sont extrêmement
bon pe norm il les faire
[Musique]
séchers c'est des pattes à domicile à la
sauge vous avez de la sauge oui on
propose de la sauge àavance c'est très
bon d'ailleurs merci merci infiniment le
rent trochin donc je rappelle B le
numéro 3 à tremblé sur moudre euh jefrey
vanlast la ferme du LOU ravissant à
bazinville le devevic Bisot tout un
fromage à Rambouillet à Rambouillet ouis
Éric barnou bah la FA coin à jou en
Josas et puis Hélène Cola les chocolats
les
chocolats
àle merci merci infiniment et bonne fête
à tous avec avec ce qu'on vous av montré
ça ça va
[Musique]
marcher